what can you advice to other filmmakers
on a technique of filming calls I don't
know what the laws are as a senior state
but yeah so you hit the nail on the head
it whether you can record a cult varies
from state to state some states or
single party some or dual party dual
party meaning that you have to say if
I'm in New York and you're in California
to say I'm recording this call are you
okay with that and they have to say yes
if it's a single party consent state
then you don't have to tell them because
one party is consenting the person
calling interesting okay so within your
state it's a it's a single party well it
depends it literally depends on what
state you're calling from and into but
it actually gets interesting in the in
the digital age because you could be
calling let's say you think you're
calling a call center in Wisconsin which
is single parties consent I believe that
call could actually route it to a call
center in florida where you need
permission from both parties so you have
to hey how's the weather out in
wisconsin all i'm actually on florida
you're like green light so you have to
you have to understand the law because
it's it's important if you get something
good and then you can't use it what's
the point you know there's other things
to where i was calling federal agencies
and they're definitely some gray area
they I'm recording this call just say it
and then they don't hang up you know
there's definitely some sensitivities
but I think for things like that i think
there's you know in advantage of people
having this information so you know you
do the best job you can to make sure
everything is fine because at some point
in time the lawyers have to review
everything and make sure you know
they're comfortable with it well it
seems like with most customer service
calls they always disclose we may be for
training purposes which they seem to
conveniently forget but any times when
they should have been recording it um so
did you watch other documentaries like
Michael Moore or Kirby dick and people
that do similar things and it's very
powerful just as it is in your film yeah
like I've watched a ton of them just for
fun like over the you I've always been a
fan of documentaries so I've seen I've
seen a lot of them and you know I think
that I guess that helps but it's such a
this is kind of like an esoteric topic
you know and it's it doesn't really make
sense and that's why you know having
instinct it's like a sense I think
people like what is that you know I
think it's um it's it's it's kind of a
hard story there's so many moving parts
and legislation and regulation and
people it's just not language that
people are typically discussing on a
daily basis it's kind of its kind of off
the radar
you